say that you're trying to describe this
set of numbers it's in between negative
three and five okay now one way you
might do this as you might say well hmm
we can see that the values are greater
than negative three so meaning to the
right of negative three and they're less
than or equal to five okay now when you
have a compound inequality what you can
do is you can write these together as
one inequality and usually that you know
this basically this occurs when they the
values are in between two numbers okay
so it's the set of all points in between
these two values now what you're going
to notice here is that I'm gonna put
these together as a compound inequality
but when you write a compound inequality
you want to write it such that the
inequality signs are less than or less
than or equal to signs like this you
don't want to write it with greater than
signs you don't want to write it like
we're one signs pointing one direction
the other signs pointing the other
direction
these are not correct what you want is
you want them to be less than signs
pointing to the left and you want the
smallest number to be over here on the
left and you want the largest value to
be over here on the right and your
variable is in between now let's see if
we can understand a little bit better so
you can see that if I cover this portion
up here X is greater than negative three
meaning that it's to the right of
negative three see how it opens to the X
and at the same time X is less than five
see how it's pointing to the X X is
smaller and in this case this particular
example X is less than or equal to five